the universe may appear random
two trillion galaxies spread across the
cosmos
[Music]
but
in this cosmic chaos scientists detect
order
when we first saw that the universe was
full of galaxies it seemed like
overwhelming chaos but it's not they are
all connected
galaxies link up in a gigantic cosmic
network spanning the entire universe
how this pattern emerged may be
cosmology's biggest puzzle
in some senses you don't understand
something unless you understand how it
comes into existence and how it's formed
and galaxies are the basic building
block of our universe
to solve this mystery scientists need to
go deep
to the very edge of the observable
universe
and study light from the first galaxies
chile 2021 scientists point the vlt
or very large telescope towards the
hubble ultra deep field
it's a patch of sky famously
photographed by the hubble space
telescope in 1995.
the vlt's power allows astronomers to
see much deeper
into space
imagine you take a grain of sand and you
put it on your fingertip
and you hold your arm out like this and
you block a part of the sky looking at
that grain of sand
that's the size of the hubble ultra deep
field and yet it contains thousands of
galaxies in it
the telescope stares at those galaxies
for 155 hours and picks up the faintest
of glows
ancient hydrogen gas concentrated along
a strand of space
15 million light years long
the filaments are just one tiny section
of the cosmic web
the largest known structure in the
universe
[Music]
the scale of the cosmic web is enormous
it is by definition the largest thing
that we can see in our universe
today the cosmic web is a lattice of
filaments linked streams of hydrogen gas
that form an intergalactic network
spanning the entire universe
inside the nodes of the cosmic web
you'll find galaxies stars black holes
along the filaments you'll find gas that
connects these nodes and the gas will
connect to the other galaxies and
clusters of galaxies it's this
beautiful super highway of large cities
that are connected through these
filaments
we can see the cosmic web about as far
back as we can look and really galaxies
are forming along that web all the way
back
this cosmic infrastructure dates back to
the earliest days of the universe
13.8 billion years ago
the universe ignites in a tiny ball of
super hot energy
it expands and begins to cool
energy transforms into primitive
subatomic particles of matter
the heat from the big bang is so intense
gravity is effectively powerless
the very early universe was super hot
super energetic and regular particles of
matter were zipping around so fast that
not even gravity could hold them
together but regular matter wasn't the
only thing in the early universe
in the background
gravity is working on something else
regular matters ghostly cousin the
invisible substance known today as dark
matter
it makes up about 85 percent of all the
matter created in the early universe
normal matter and dark matter both
existed around the time of the big bang
but the way they played out was very
different
just 10 seconds after the big bang the
infant universe is billions of degrees
fahrenheit still far too hot for regular
matter particles to clump together
but dark matter
plays by different rules
dark matter isn't affected by the big
bang's intense radiation in the same way
that regular matter is and so because
it's able to cool it clumps together in
a way that regular matter doesn't
as dark matter clumps grow they exert a
gravitational pull and begin to form
shadowy structures
as soon as the dark matter gets a
foothold we have a place where there's a
bit more stuff
then that attracts more and more dark
matter
380 000 years after the big bang the
intense heat drops to a few thousand
degrees
normal particles of matter move around
more slowly protons and electrons bind
together and form atoms of hydrogen and
helium gas
then
gravity from dark matter starts to work
on regular matter
before you know it you have this very
clumpy universe with these huge dark
matter halos
that can now start to draw in also
ordinary matter in the form of gas
a billion year building project begins
the dark matter clumps pull in clouds of
gas
the foundations of the cosmic web
and the galaxies
just as when you build a building you
know there's a lot of work that happens
before the building goes up our universe
spent a lot of time laying the
groundwork for this cosmic web before it
switched on the lights
the foundations are complete but the job
isn't finished
how did those clouds of gas transform
into the greatest structure in the
universe
the secretive dark matter that brought
the gas together is also on site
managing the build
it was really the dark matter that
called the shots in in cosmic clustering
because it outweighed the ordinary stuff
by by a big factor
in essence the cosmic web is made of
dark matter tendrils of material are
stretched out across the cosmos
as the sprawling structure builds its
gravitational pull strengthens pulling
in more dark matter the clumps begin to
collapse and shrink down into filaments
these meet at even more tightly packed
clusters creating a huge dark scaffold
that drags in more hydrogen gas
imagine drops of dew on a spider web
that's like hydrogen blobs being pulled
into dark matter's cosmic web
after tens of millions of years of
construction
strands of gas stretch across the cosmos
fast forward to now
the web appears in all its star-spangled
glory lit up with galaxies we know at
some point stars and galaxies formed the
big question is when what were the first
galaxies like
that's a big mystery so how then did the
lights of the cosmos switch on
evidence suggests that as the universe
assembled its web of dark matter and
hydrogen gas
the biggest stars that have ever lived
set the cosmos ablaze
[Music]
you